wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute live
und heute mit einem Thema wo wir alle
mit anpacken können was uns alle
betrifft es geht um die Überlastung
unserer Notfallversorgung wir zeigen
euch heute wie kaputt dieses System
aktuell ist wir wollen über Probleme
sprechen die es gibt wir wollen aber
auch über Lösungen sprechen denn aktuell
stellen wir uns die Frage Notruf und
keiner kommt Fragezeichen das Ziel muss
er aber sein dass es am Ende heißt
Notruf und die Rettung kommt
Ausrufezeichen ich freue mich riesig
dass ihr bei uns im Stream seid ich
freue mich so sehr dass wir schon so
viele Fragen und Kommentare an uns
geschickt habe das zeigt wie wichtig
euch auch das Thema ist über das wir
heute sprechen und noch mehr freue ich
mich dass wir mit
Rettungssanitäter Luis Teichmann und
Gesundheitsexperte Professor Thomas
Kraft zwei wirklich tolle
Gesprächspartner hier am Start haben mit
denen wir überall eure Fragen natürlich
auch wie immer sehr gerne sprechen
wollen der erste ist Luis Teichmann da
sehen wir hi Luis 26 Jahre alt und ich
muss sagen für mich hier als 24-Jährigen
auch echt schon ein ein Vorbild ich will
euch das ganz kurz sagen nach seinem
Abitur hatte einen freiwilliges soziales
Jahr im Rettungsdienst absolviert ist
dort dann auch Rettungssanitäter
geworden weil ihm da aber auch schon
Probleme und die Überlastung klar
geworden ist hat er gesagt nee so geht
das nicht ich muss irgendwie was machen
um zu sehen wo gibt es auch Lösungen hat
dann ein Studium in
rettungsingenieurwesen gemacht hatte an
Lösungen an Konzepten gearbeitet ja und
jetzt zeigt uns allen wie es gehen kann
auf tiktok Instagram youtube ist Luis
bekannt als fünf unterstrich
sprechwunsch und teilt er seine
Erfahrungen im Alltag und die
lösungswünsche und heute auch freue ich
mich sehr dass du bei ZDF heute live zu
Gast bin bis Heiligkeit Mann hi danke
für die Einladung und danke für die
Blumen
bevor wir sprechen Louis wollen wir uns
alle rein versetzen in eure Arbeit und
eure Lage als Rettungssanitäter und das
zeigen uns Markus groß und Stefanie Hein
an einem Beispiel aus Berlin
wir haben einen Platz Zustand bei
unbekannten psychiatrischen Notfall ein
Mensch ist in Not Alltag auf dem
Rettungswagen noch auf der Rückfahrt vom
letzten Einsatz erreicht das Team schon
der nächste Ruf so ist es oft RTW 12041
quält sich hier durch Berlin aber ist
die deutschlandweit ähnlich aus Retter
beklagen dass es immer mehr
Einsatzfahrten gibt oft für
Kleinigkeiten es zu wenig
Rettungspersonal gibt und deshalb oft
Wagen auf der Straße fehlen was die
Arbeit für die anderen natürlich
vermehrt diese Gemengelage kann
gefährlich werden
das läuft in eine Katastrophe so würde
ich es einfach mal ganz schlicht und
einfach bezeichnen wir werden in der
Zukunft wenn wir jetzt nicht ändern
nicht mehr genug Rettungswagen auf der
Straße haben um jeden einen anzubieten
und dann werden Sie entweder warten oder
wir werden Zustände haben wo sie alleine
in ein Krankenhaus gefahren müssen um
eine Versorgung zu bekommen der
Rettungsdienst in Deutschland ist
überlastet
t für nicht einmal daran dass wir lange
brauchen um einen Krankenhaus mit einem
freien Bett zu finden an der
Einsatzstelle dass wir aber auch an den
Krankenhäusern durch die
Belastungssituation in den
Krankenhäusern lange Wartezeiten haben
bis das Rettungsfachpersonal aber auch
die Notärzte den Patienten an die
Krankenhäuser weitergeben können und wer
noch in der Notaufnahme ansteht fehlt
auf der Straße als die Berliner Retter
bei der psychischen Notlage vom Anfang
der Geschichte eintreffen steht der
Rauchen vor seiner Haustür und will in
die Klinik gefahren werden sie versuchen
sich nicht zu ärgern
da sind schon viele Probleme angeklungen
aber vielleicht direkt auch die Frage an
dich was erlebst du in deinem Alltag
ja im Prinzip genau das gleiche also ich
bezeichne das immer als twenty four
seven Service Mentalität
gestiegenes gepaart mit einem
gestiegenen Gesundheitsbewusstsein dass
ich ausgeprägt hat in der Gesellschaft
beschleunigt deutlich beschleunigt durch
die Pandemie die eben dazu führt dass
man den Anspruch hat auch ja
kleinste
Beschwerden zu jeder Tag und Nacht Zeit
Notfall im Rahmen der notfallförderung
abklären zu lassen und das gipfelt dann
meist darin dass eben der Rettungsdienst
alarmiert wird und ähm wie die Patienten
dann weil wir natürlich auch nichts
ausschließen können oder begrenzte
diagnostische Möglichkeiten haben den
Patienten in einer Notaufnahme zu führen
und
auch diese diese gerade dieser gerade
angesprochene Patient der dann im Stehen
oder rauchend unten wartet auch das ist
so ein klassisches großstädtisches
Problem also wir haben sehr viele
sogenannte drehtür-patienten die
wirklich pro Tag teilweise auch
mehrfachkontakt mit dem Rettungsdienst
haben und das natürlich auch gepaart mit
dem demografischen Wandel den wir in
Deutschland beobachten dass viele
Patienten jetzt bettlägerig sind oder
eben aufgrund ihres Alters nicht mehr so
mobil sind und somit sich vielleicht
auch den Gang zum Arzt vermehrt sparen
das in der Summe treibt die
Einsatzzahlen deutlich nach oben wichtig
ist glaube ich jetzt an der Stelle auch
Kommunikation und auch gleich noch mal
dass du auch deine Perspektive darauf
schilderst weil den Fall wie wir ihn
auch im Beitrag gehört haben da sind
auch schon einige Kommentare bei uns
reingekommen z.B von Marinella sie hat
geschrieben ich benötigt haben am
zweiten Weihnachtstag ein Arzt für meine
schwer kranke Mutter die bei uns lebt
man wird dann zu
11617 verwiesen Telefonnummern klären
wir später ich versuchte es den ganzen
Tag jedoch ohne Erfolg das ist natürlich
dann für die die Leute dort eine
Herausforderung dass die so damit
umgehen müssen aber wichtig damit solche
Situationen nicht entstehen und am Ende
gar nicht geholfen werden kann ist ja
beide Perspektiven also vielleicht auch
deine darauf was du im Alltag erlebst
und auch auf solche Fälle
ja richtig also das angesprochene
Beispiel gerade ist jetzt auch nichts
Ungewöhnliches also wir sind auch sehr
oft beim Patienten und natürlich wenn
wir merken okay das ist jetzt vielleicht
ein Einsatz der mehr so Richtung in die
Allgemeinmedizin gehört dann fragen wir
natürlich okay haben Sie denn mein
Hausarzt kontaktiert oder die 11617 den
ärztlich Notdienst kontaktiert und dann
kommt meist als Antwort ja das haben wir
versucht wir hängen da jetzt allerdings
über eine halbe Stunde in der
Warteschleife und die sagten wenn es
nicht besser wird oder wie dann sollen
wir die 112 wählen und werde einzeln
zwei ist es nun mal so man kann es Luxus
nennen man kann es auch ja das ist immer
das System geschuldet dass man dort dann
meist innerhalb von 8 Minuten in der
Stadt ein Rettungswagen vor der Tür
stehen hat also Fachpersonal dass ich
zumindest mal da so eine erst
Einschätzung verleiten lassen kann und
ähm das merken wir auf jeden Fall dass
viele Einsätze die eigentlich originär
vielleicht ein Zuständigkeit auch das
ärztlichen Notdienstes gehören zu uns
zurückkommen und da kann man natürlich
dann den Patienten noch gar keinen
Vorwurf machen
absolut konnen wir auch noch mal auf die
Situation wie wie ihr sie erlebt da
haben wir auch einen konkretes Beispiel
zum Personalnotstand bekommen einen User
hat uns geschrieben er Fischen sich List
das ganz kurz vor er kann es für seine
Wache sagen seit Anfang 2020 haben sich
die Einsätze sagt er verdreifacht von ca
120 pro Monat auf bisher 368 das wird
gemeistert mit 28 Kollegen davon drei
halbtageskräfte drei Azubis 4 sind
dauerhaft krank zwei haben schon
gekündigt zwei weitere werden im
nächsten Jahr gehen sind das auch so
Fakten die du für dich persönlich
erlebst und kannst du das auch
bestätigen
auf jeden Fall ein Kollege sagte
kürzlich zu mir danach über 22 Jahren
aus dem Rettungsdienst ausgeschieden ist
weil er gesagt hat ich kann das nicht
mehr ich bin im Burnout der sagte zu mir
als ich ihm so mein Leid geschildert hat
was mich so stört sagt der krass Louis
da habe ich 22 Jahre für gebraucht um an
genau den Punkt zu kommen für den du
jetzt 8 Jahre gebraucht hast und ich
bemerke wenn ich jetzt mit jungen
Auszubildenden sprechen dass die mir
schon teilweise nach einem Jahr oder
zwei Jahre voll und der Job sagen ich
kann das nicht mehr die gucken sich nach
Studiengängen um etc oder reduzieren
sogar die Arbeitszeit weil die Belastung
ebenso groß geworden ist und das ist auf
jeden Fall etwas was ich aus meiner
Perspektive heraus auf jeden Fall
bestätigen kann
wir sammeln jetzt noch mal weiter
Perspektiven um auch uns der
Problembeschreibung zu nähern da haben
wir auch eine aus der Vergangenheit von
Rainer Druck er sagt uns ich war 11
Jahre Rettungsassistent bin jetzt zehn
Jahre nicht mehr dabei wir hatten damals
schon die Situation und auch die
Diskussion über mehr Personal auch im
notarztbereich wo oft die Situation war
dass einer da war auch kürzere
Anfahrtswege wurden regelmäßig
besprochen aber es ist anscheinend so
schreibt er noch schlimmer geworden und
nicht besser
er schreibt auch er war Betriebsarzt bei
Betriebsrat bei kastenverhandlungen was
da abgeht sagt er sei das Grauen da geht
es nicht um die Patienten nur darum
womöglichkeit besteht einzusparen da
wird um jeden Bleistift gefeilt sind das
auch so Wahrnehmungen die du hast die du
mit Kollegen teilst in der aktuellen
Situation also wenn wir von der
Vergangenheit in die Gegenwart gehen
definitiv also das Thema Kosten fällt
einem glaube ich überall auf die Füße
das merkt man schon daran dass wir ja
leider auch überhaupt gar kein
einheitlichen Standard in Deutschland
haben wieder Rettungsdienst ausgestattet
ist also man merkt deutlich wenn man
sich in Rettungswagen anschaut oder der
Rettungsdienstler wenn er von dem
Rettungswagen steht merkt er direkt okay
die Kommune hat Geld in die Hand
genommen die Kommune hat kein Geld in
die Hand genommen und das wirkt sich
natürlich auch auf das Berufsbild also
es ist immer noch üblich und das sorgt
wirklich für eine sehr große
Unzufriedenheit die sogenannte
Faktorisierung der Arbeitszeit das
bedeutet dass die Leute 48 Stunden die
Woche arbeiten müssen aber nur 40
Stunden lang bezahlt werden für 40
Stunden weil es ja heißt dass es der
Rest in die Bereitschaftszeit fällt und
sie deshalb ja nicht die ganze Zeit
Einsätze fahren sondern ja auch mal auf
der Couch liegen und auch das ist
natürlich im gewissen Maße in einem
Kostendruck geschuldet und das merkt man
wie gesagt nicht nur unter den den
Arbeitsbedingungen Arbeitsvertrag
sondern eben auch gegeben ebenfalls an
seinem täglichen Handwerkzeug wo man ja
sagen würde okay wenigstens hier sollte
man ja insbesondere in so einem Land wie
Deutschland auch wirklich bestes
Material und beste Vernetzung legen aber
auch hier hängt man leider hinterher
es kommen richtig viele Kommentare von
Euch rein ich nehme noch mal ein mit von
Strucken Hose 8877 sie schreibt arbeite
im Krankenhaus ich habe eine Ausbildung
zum Rettungssanitäter gemacht so sehr
ich meinen Job auch Liebe unter den
aktuellen Umständen kann ich wie man
dazu raten der schreibt sie eine
Ausbildung zu machen die Probleme sind
seit Jahren bekannt leider wurde
geklatscht statt ernsthaft etwas zu
verändern Thema Politik dazu kommen wir
gleich weil wir sind erstmal noch beim
Thema Perspektiven sammeln wir haben die
von Rettungssanitätern aus der
Vergangenheit gehört wir haben jetzt
deine gehört und wir sind bei dem Thema
Probleme Probleme in den Strukturen wir
haben das Bündnis pro Rettungsdienst im
Beitrag gehört die haben auch vor
wenigen Tagen Anfang Dezember noch mal
einen Appell losgeschickt in Form an die
Öffentlichkeit nach dem Motto hey wir
sind im Limit wir können das nicht mehr
machen und auch du hast das schon getan
in Sachen Öffentlichkeit tust das bei
Instagram bei tiktok und auch in deinem
Buch Einsatz am Limit was im
Rettungsdienst schief läuft und warum
uns das alle angeht da kommst du auf das
Thema an einem Beispiel nur wo wir
gleich bei den Strukturen sind vernetzte
Navigationssysteme wenn wir Perspektiven
vernetzen wollen müssen wir natürlich
auch Navigationssysteme vernetzen im
Klartext was heißt das der Notruf kommt
in die Zentrale an und dann kann die
Adressen dann digital in die
Navigationssysteme geschickt werden und
man muss das nicht mehr Hände ist
eintippen wir haben beide aber vor der
Sendung schon gesprochen da hast du uns
gesagt schön wärst wir bekommen bei uns
noch Plan Quadrate aus dem Atlas
geschickt
ja genau das ist so sehr schönes
Beispiel weil das ja eigentlich so auf
der Hand liegt dass man sich so ein
ideales System vorstellt von Anfang bis
Ende durchdacht und vernetzt dass der
Anruf eingeht die Adresse lokalisiert
wird vielleicht sogar schon
automatisiert und dann natürlich direkt
an die Besatzung übermittelt wird und
das haben auch einige Kommunen in
Deutschland aber und das ist halt
irgendwie das erschreckende das ist
flächendeckend einfach nicht der Fall
also eine so eine einfache Lösung die ja
in in anderen Ländern absolut Usus ist
selbst da ist man aus Kostengründen
vielleicht aber auch umsetzungsgründen
oder aus aus Gründen der Fehlplanung hat
man sich dazu noch nicht durchdringen zu
können dass man deutschlandweit auf
solche Möglichkeiten zurückgreifen kann
und zu bedient man sich vielerorts noch
Faxgeräten und analogen Möglichkeiten um
dann eben sowas wichtiges wie zum
Beispiel den Einsatzort zu finden und da
muss man eben auch sagen das kann
natürlich auch und dann im Ernstfall
wichtige Sekunden Kosten weil jeder weiß
dass nicht jedes Haus super mit der
Hausnummer direkt zu erkennen ist manche
liegen so ein bisschen im rückwärtigen
Bereich bei manchen Häusern oder
Adressen muss man so gewisse Dinge
beachten und da gibt es eben digitale
oder Softwarelösungen die da deutlich
überlegen sind und auch der Ortskenntnis
überlegen sind wenn man vielleicht auch
jung ist noch nicht so viel Ortskenntnis
hat und ja das ist so ein Punkt finde
ich den man super leicht beheben könnte
aber wo man eben merkt dass es da schon
dran hat und vielleicht ein Aspekt noch
es gibt dann natürlich auch die
Grenzbereiche da neben mal das Beispiel
das passiert ein Unfalls in einem
Grenzbereich von zwei Städten oder
Kommunen wie ist da die aktuelle
Situation
ja das ist auch so ein Problem im
Rettungsdienst also auch der
Rettungsdienst unterwirft sich ja dem
Föderalismus allerdings ist es so dass
ein sehr vielen Bundesländern der
Rettungsdienst abgegeben wird an die
jeweiligen Kommunen NRW zum Beispiel ist
da so ein Paradebeispiel das bedeutet
jeder Kreis und jede kreisfreie Stadt
planen ihren eigenen Rettungsdienst
haben gegebenenfalls Ihre eigenen
Leitstellen ihre eigenen Fahrzeugflotten
und das führt eben dazu weil die
untereinander nur im wirklichen
Ausnahmefall sich vernetzen also wenn
keine Rettungsmittel mehr verfügbar sind
das ist wirklich so ist dass wenn im
Landkreis ah der Rettungswagen zwei
Kilometer von der Einsatzstelle die aber
im Landkreis B liegt entfernt ist dass
dann trotzdem der Rettungswagen der
unter Umständen länger braucht aus dem
Landkreis B anfährt und nicht der aus
dem Landkreis ah einfach weil man sich
die Ressourcen nicht sinnvoll aufteilt
und auch da sage ich im Sinne eines
optimalen Rettungsdienst das würde man
ja solche Gebietsgrenzen gar nicht haben
und man muss sich ja fragen was ist das
beste für den Patienten dass der RTW aus
seiner Stadt kommt oder das einfach der
nächste verfügbare Rettungswagen
betrifft und ich denke zweiteres ja
jetzt haben wir über Probleme gesprochen
aber auch schon über den Aspekt Lösungen
lass uns dabei bleiben und auch über
Lösungen sprechen wie können wir diese
Situation verbessern das erste wichtige
Thema dabei die richtige Telefonnummer
wählen so ist es zum Beispiel bei
schweren Unfällen und lebensbedrohlichen
Notfällen da ist natürlich dann gegeben
die 112 zu wählen so erreicht man dann
eben Notarzt und Rettungswagen und auch
die Feuerwehr handelt es sich aber nicht
um einen solchen Notfall dann sollte man
den ärztlichen Bereitschaftsdienst unter
der Nummer
116117 anrufen der ist für Patienten da
die außerhalb der regulären Sprechzeiten
dringend ärztliche Hilfe brauchen auch
diese Nummer die ist zu jeder Zeit
erreichbar benötigt man jetzt einen
Transport z.B zu Klinik oder zum Arzt
dann sollte man nach der eigenen Vorwahl
die 1922 wählen inzwischen ist diese
Nummer nicht mehr nur für Notfälle
sondern lediglich zum Krankentransport
gedacht
jetzt sind wir bei dem Punkt den wir
auch vorhin schon hatten man hat einmal
die Situation von Betroffenen die
natürlich diese Situation einer
leidenden Patientin oder ein Patienten
sehen aus der Familie auch eine enorme
Belastung Situation jetzt ist aber
natürlich auch die Belastungssituation
für euch aber da vielleicht trotzdem mit
Hilfe von anderen auf die richtige
Nummer zu kommen das wäre auch eine
entscheidende Entlastung um von jeder
Seite glaube ich druck nehmen zu können
oder
definitiv also es ist natürlich so dass
wenn man die einzelnen zwei wählt und
der Leitstellen Disponent in der
Leitstelle für sich erkennt okay das
könnte jetzt ein Einsatz sein der
vielleicht eher im Zuständigkeitsbereich
des ärztlichen Notdienstes liegt dann
wird er den Patienten darauf hinweisen
oder ihm gegebenfalls das Anbieten das
Problem ist auch er liegt natürlich in
dieser rechtlichen Grauzone wenn der
Patient dann da eine halbe Stunde in der
Warteschleife hängt und dann vielleicht
selbst fährt und am Ende hat er dann
doch vielleicht eine bedrohliche
Erkrankung dann dann muss er unter
Umständen dafür dann wird er dafür unter
Umständen Regress genommen und deshalb
für das eben dazu dass die Leitstellen
eher tendenziellen Rettungswagen einmal
zu viel rausschicken als einmal zu wenig
das natürlich wichtig ich denke aber
wenn man kann den Patienten insofern
kein Vorwurf machen als dass der Patient
der im Rahmen seiner schulischen Bildung
kaum Kontakt bekommen hat mit dem
Gesundheitssystem also wir lernen ja
überhaupt gar nicht was das Thema wissen
ja gar nicht wie funktioniert das und
ich denke deshalb auch dass Reihe
überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist für sich
selbst einzuschätzen bin ich jetzt ein
Fall für die 112 für die 116117 oder
kann ich am nächsten Tag zum Hausarzt
gehen oder oder und da gibt es eine
jüngst veröffentlichte Studie der Uni
Maastricht die eben von der Bertelsmann
Stiftungen Auftrag gegeben wurde die
eben so ein sogenannten single point of
contact fordert das ist auch in vielen
Ländern Standard wo man eben eine Nummer
anruft und die weist einen dann eine
Versorgungsstufe im Gesundheitssystem zu
und so kann man eben die Patienten
Ströme besser lenken und kann eben auch
gleichzeitig aushebeln dass der Patient
sich aussucht aber jetzt was für die 112
ist die 116 117 oder eben die
Notaufnahme der letztlich muss man ja
sagen als Laie kann man das ja nur
schwierig einschätzen für mich ist jetzt
vielleicht ein ähm der klassische
eingewachsene Zehnagel nichts Besonderes
es kann Patienten geben so kurios das
erscheinen mag für die ist das auf
einmal Lebensgefahr und dann sind die
halt nach ihrer Definition auch was für
die einsetzen
ja da sprichst du schon an worüber wir
gleich auch mit Professor Thomas Kraft
noch mal weiter sprechen wollen bleiben
noch mal ganz kurz bei dir da kommt die
Frage von Tuna Sounds und zwar an Dich
welche Vorstellungen du an die Politik
hast was sie genau tun muss um die
Situation deutlich zu verbessern
vielleicht noch ganz kurz Kontext ja
noch da und der gesundheitspolitische
Sprecher der Grünen Fraktion der hat
heute auch noch mal eine große Reform
der Notfallversorgung angekündigt dass
sei ein zentrales Ziel und auch eine von
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
eingesetzte Expertenkommission sie soll
das auch erarbeiten so Luis ich für das
beides zusammen weil du bist jemand der
hat sich im Studium damit sehr sehr
intensiv auseinandergesetzt wurdest du
eigentlich auch mal gefragt wie so eine
Lösung eigentlich aussehen konnte
von bundespolitischer Seite tatsächlich
noch nie es ist schon so dass man ab und
zu kommt ein Kommunalpolitiker oder auch
ein Politiker der irgendwie im Landtag
sitzt und sagt mal ja wo sind denn so
die Probleme wir müssen mal reden da
kann ich allerdings sagen also ich bin
da immer gesprächsbereit aber solche
Gespräche verlaufen sehr oft im Sande
und da entsteht im Prinzip nie was draus
und ich bin eben auch der Meinung sowas
muss man erstmal auf bundespolitischer
Ebene angehen man muss sich darüber
Gedanken machen möchten wir eigentlich
das Rettungsdienst überall anders
funktioniert in Deutschland also das ist
ja so die die Kernfrage möchte ich dass
jeder Patient zu jeder Tag und Nacht
Zeit die gleiche medizinische Versorgung
mit der gleichen Qualität erhält dann
würde ich ja sagen ja dann muss man sich
ja fragen warum ist das dann nicht so
warum backt dann jedes Bundesland
irgendwie die eigenen Brötchen und
insofern sind das schon weichen die
müssen das bundespolitischer Ebene
gestellt werden auch im fünften
Sozialgesetzbuch
damit man dann überhaupt das ganze an
die Länder weitergeben kann und die dann
entsprechend auf die Kommunen aber da
hat tatsächlich noch keinen Kontakt
stattgefunden
aber was gäbe es aus deiner Sicht für
Lösungsansätze die die Situation
verbessern könnten
also man muss eine Lösung ist aus meiner
Sicht wenn man sich anschaut was wir für
Versorgungsstufen haben twentyfour seven
dann 24/7 dann ist ja im Prinzip eine
große Lücke da wo der Hausarzt der
ärztliche Notdienst aufhört und da wo
der Rettungsdienst beginnt da ist eine
riesige Lücke von Patienten die nicht so
genau wissen wo gehöre ich jetzt genau
hin ich bin nicht so dass ich jetzt in
einer Stunde tot bin aber irgendwie
fühle ich mich auch nicht gut und ich
denke ein wichtiges Mittel oder ein
wichtiges Werkzeug wäre es wenn wir viel
mehr Versorgungsstufen etablieren sprich
Notfall Krankentransportwagen wie in der
Studie gefordert auch Gemeinde
Notfallsanitäter und vielleicht auch den
ärztlichen Notdienst ein bisschen besser
ausstatten dass wir eben den Patienten
viel mehr anbieten können und somit
wirklich die die Notfallrettung die die
jetzt also wirklich kommen sollen wenn
es hart kommt die somit ein bisschen
entlasten können denn es gibt viele
Einsätze für den Rettungswagen wo man
sagt okay der Patient muss ins
Krankenhaus aber jetzt gerade geht es um
den reinen Transport da braucht man
jetzt keinen großen von medizinischen
Geräte wie wir das haben also reicht es
gegebenenfalls auch wenn das ein
Krankentransportwagen Schrägstrich
notfallkranken Transportwagen macht und
ich denke damit kann man schon viel
Druck aus dem System nehmen zum einen
und zum anderen muss man das System aber
auch wieder interessant machen für junge
notfallsanitäterinnen und
rettungssanitäterinnen die sich für
dieses Berufsbild entscheiden und da
muss es eben darum gehen dass man den
Beruf so attraktiv macht zum Beispiel
eben das durch Abschaffung dieser
Faktorisierung der Arbeitszeiten die man
sich auch anschaut okay ähm wie wie es
ist so eine optimale Aufteilung der
Schichtzeiten also es gibt Kollegen die
fahren wirklich vier Nachtdienste die
Woche wo man schon weiß okay das ist ja
nicht gesund und
ich denke nicht mal dass man da mit Geld
irgendwas Großes bewirken kann also Geld
schafft aus meiner Sicht keine
Zufriedenheit sondern hilft vielleicht
der Unzufriedenheit ab sondern im
Gesamtpaket muss man eben gucken okay
kann man vielleicht auch steuerlich
Erleichterung schaffen oder den Leuten
irgendwo Entgegenkommen im Privatleben
dass sie halt sagen okay es ist ein
harter Job ich bin im Rettungsdienst
aber ich habe so viele benefits dadurch
auch wenn ich jetzt vergleichsweise
moderat verdiene deshalb bleibe ich auch
hier und ich habe es deshalb gar nicht
nötig irgendwie zu studieren
vielen Dank an Luis Teichmann
Rettungssanitäter und folgt ihm gern für
mehr Eindrücke und noch mehr Eindrücke
aus seinem Alltag und auch Lösungen fünf
unterstrich sprech Wunsch bei tiktok
Instagram YouTube und hier heute
herzlichen Dank für deine Zeit bei ZDF
heute live danke für die Einladung
ja und wie wichtig es ist Druck von
allen Seiten zu nehmen in diesem ganzen
System das erklärt uns und zeigt uns
jetzt noch mal auch ein weiterer
Rettungssanitäter vom Deutschen Roten
Kreuz und er zeigt uns wirklich
anschaulich an seinem Beispiel wie
wichtig bessere Arbeitsbedingungen und
die Entlastung sind ja da waren wir bei
einem älteren Patienten in einem
Pflegeheim der eine schwere Atemnot
aufgrund einer Corona Infektion hatte
und den haben wir dann vor Ort
stabilisiert und wollten ihnen eine
Klinik bringen da haben wir mehrere
Kliniken ab telefoniert und bestimmt
eine halbe Dreiviertelstunde telefoniert
was bis dahin geführt hat dass eine der
aufnehmen in der Kliniken und seine
Notärztin dazu und hat den Patienten vor
Ort zu paliieren ihm ein Medikament zu
spritzen das beruhigt und die Atemnot
nimmt und dann aber eben vor Ort in die
letzte Konsequenz sterben zu lassen
dagegen entschieden und gesagt wir
müssen den Patienten trotzdem mitnehmen
weil das können wir ethisch auch nicht
vertreten und dann haben wir eine Klinik
Zwangs belegt und das ging dann auch
irgendwie und ein paar Tage später
konnte der Patient dann auch ohne Folgen
seine corona-infektion wieder in das
Pflegeheim entlassen werden
Felix Dahm war das der uns da noch mal
ein wirklich sehr eindrücklichen Fall
geschildert hat eine bemutige und
bewundernswerte Entscheidung aber die
auch noch mal gezeigt hat unter was für
einem Druck da wirklich alle Beteiligten
in der Notfallversorgung stehen und da
ist es ja total menschlich wo so ein
Druck herrscht da können Fehler
passieren deswegen Druck minimieren
haben wir festgehalten und können jetzt
weiter vertiefen die Lösungen mit Thomas
Kraft er ist jetzt bei uns herzlich
Willkommen bei uns im Stream
Gesundheitswesen Experte und unter
anderem auch Professor an der
Universität in Maastricht herzlich
Willkommen bei uns genau danke für die
Einladung
Herr Kraft auch Luis hat schon
angesprochen wir können mal ganz kurz
hier gemeinsam auf meinen Laptop schauen
sie haben gemeinsam mit der Battles man
Stiftung und der björnsteiger Stiftung
eine Studie im November herausgegeben
Notfallversorgung und Rettungsdienst in
Deutschland und hier unten steht
Partikularismus versus Systemdenken so
jetzt kann ich persönlich bin ich
ehrlich nur erahnen was sie damit meint
vielleicht können sie es mir ganz kurz
erklären was ist da genau der Kern der
die Lösung vielleicht auch beschreibt
also Herr Teichmann hat das eben ja
schon mehrfach angesprochen wir haben
das Problem in Deutschland dass wir die
Zuständigkeit für die Umsetzung des
Rettungsdienstes bei den 16
Bundesländern haben die zum Teil das
wieder delegiert haben an die kommunalen
Gebietskörperschaften und das führt
allein schon zu einer großen
Heterogenität dann haben wir im
Gesundheitswesen ein klar
durchstrukturierer strukturierten
sektorenbereich
die
hausärztliche Versorgung die
Krankenhausversorgung andere
Versorgungsbereiche alle die wirken aber
in den Rettungsdienst und in die
Notfallversorgung mit rein sind aber
getrennt finanziert und versuchen auch
ihre eigenen Bereiche
zu verteidigen und
selber zu entwickeln
daneben haben wir den Bereich der nicht
polizeilichen Gefahrenabwehr also
Feuerwehren Katastrophenschutz die
wieder in den Bereich Leitstelle und in
dem Bereich Notruf 112 zusammenkommen
und dort auch eigene Interessen
verfolgen mit eigenen Interessen meine
ich nicht dass das irgendwas negatives
ist sondern jeder hat seine fachliche
Sicht seine fachlichen Anspruch aber die
passen nicht unbedingt direkt zusammen
und das führt dazu so wie es Herr
Teichmann E-Mail auch geschrieben hat
dass wir unterschiedliche Standards
haben dass wir unterschiedliche
versorgungssicherheiten noch haben und
dass wir
Schwierigkeiten haben den Bereich
koordiniert weiterzuentwickeln im
Rettungsdienst kommt hinzu dass er im
Grunde nicht aus einem Guss geplant ist
sondern seit den 60er Jahren sich
Schritt für Schritt entwickelt hat
gewachsen ist gewachsene Strukturen die
auch wirken dass wir nicht unbedingt
gemessen an den Standards
in 2022
unbedingt optimale Strukturen haben und
diese ganze Gemengelage
führt dazu dass wir obwohl wir ständig
über diese Reform Problematiken und
Reform fordernissen Reden an den Punkten
wirklich nicht wesentlich weiterkommen
deswegen ist in der Studie die sie eben
angesprochen haben die diese dass wir
eine grundlegende Veränderung brauchen
Systemdenken
[Musik]
systemisch die Notwendigkeiten
betrachten und dementsprechend dann auch
Lösungen finden auf den
unterschiedlichen Ebenen wieder für
zuständig sind da gehen wir Kraft ganz
kurz da gehen wir gleich dann im Detail
noch mal drauf ein wenn wir bei dem
Thema Lösungen sind ich will ganz kurz
noch mal festhalten das was sie auch
angesprochen haben die Probleme in der
Struktur das kommt auch in unserer
Community rüber dass es sozusagen großes
Lob an die Rettungssanitäter auch an
Luis kommt von Chris Wolf z.B mein Vater
benötigte vor einem halben Jahr ein
Rettungsdienst er kann wirklich nur Lob
aussprechen beeindruckend was für eine
Ruhe die beiden Rettungsfahrer
ausgestrahlt haben wir hatten in jeder
Sekunde den Eindruck dass sie alles im
Griff haben wirklich wundervolle Arbeit
jetzt haben Sie Herr Kraft und uns auch
schon die Probleme in der Entwicklung
skizziert und dazu hat Merle ein
Kommentar bei uns beim vergangenen Jahr
aus ihrer gefühlten Wahrnehmung der Wurm
drin sie selbst habe zweimal den
Rettungsdienst benötigt auf einer
aufgrund einer Erkrankung kollabiert
ihre Schwiegermutter hatte ein
Herzstillstand und später einen fragt
die alterskräfte die waren aber allesamt
sehr kompetent sagt sie geduldig
vertrauenserweckend sie hat sich sofort
wohlgefühlt dann kann alle an diese
wertvolle Arbeit so jetzt lesen wir da
aber auch raus es hapert an den
Strukturen ein weiterer Kommentar die
Problematik ist jedoch dass die 116 117
zum Beispiel auch überlastet ist keine
erreicht wird somit würden dann
Patienten dann doch wieder den RTW rufen
er kauft sie haben in ihrer Studie aber
auch Best Practice Beispiele die sich
lösen von Deutschland ins Ausland gucken
aufgezählt ohne zu sagen das ist jetzt
wirklich besser oder schlecht da aber
von welchen Ländern können wir uns
welche konkreten Dinge anschauen um
wirklich auch zu einer guten Lösung zu
kommen
ich glaube dass wir zum Beispiel uns die
Leitstelle Kopenhagen oder die
Leitstelle Niederösterreich als
Beispiele nehmen können um den Punkt den
vorhin auch von von Herrn Teichmann
schon angesprochen worden ist
weiterzuentwickeln nehme ich das alle
diese Anrufe 116 117 112 die anderen die
19 Nummern dass das an einer Stelle
zusammen läuft dort
ordentlich bewertet wird und dann die
Versorgungsmöglichkeiten den Patienten
geboten werden die Sie tatsächlich
brauchen dazu braucht man aber auch
Abfrage Algorithmen die klinisch
validiert sind und die sicherstellen
dass tatsächlich eine
aufgrund der abfragebildes eine
ausreichend sichere Entscheidung
getroffen werden kann schon da Arbeits
in Deutschland aber weil wir im Grunde
in den mehr als 300 Leitstellen ganz
unterschiedliche abfrage-
durchstrukturiert und standardisiert bis
hin zu freier Bewertung durch das
jeweilige Fachpersonal das in den
Leitstellen arbeitet bei letzterem wenn
wir diese freien Abfrage haben dann
taucht immer das Problem auf was ist
direkt wo ist die Rechtssicherheit
müssen wir nicht doch sicherheitshalber
ein Rettungswagen schicken haben wir
standardisiert und strukturierte
notabrufabfrage die klinische validiert
ist und kann kontinuierlich überprüfe
dem Qualitätsmanagement dann können wir
auch ausreichend sicher entscheiden wir
schicken eben nicht den Notarzt die
schicken nicht den Rettungswagen sondern
wir schicken eine andere besser
geeignete
besser geeignetes Einsatzmittel oder wir
verweisen den Patienten auf seinen
Hausarzt in den nächsten Tagen oder
laden ihn zu Selbstmedikation alles das
geht aber nur dann wenn man tatsächlich
ausreichende Sicherheit hat mit
standardisierten strukturierten
abfragesystemen so wie sie in
Kopenhagen oder in Niederösterreich oder
auch in den Niederlanden oder
Großbritannien
Standard sind seit vielen Jahren
sie haben und das vielleicht als
abschließende Frage dann wenn wir wieder
den Blick vom Ausland auch wieder zu uns
auf Deutschland blicken und nicht auf
die Probleme sondern auf die Ziele sie
haben in der Studie ein Zielbild für
Deutschland formuliert was genau umfasst
dieses Zielbild
wir haben in der Studie gefordert dass
wir ein umfassendes Zielbild benötigen
und wir haben Parameter genannt die wir
für
grundsätzlich notwendig halten dass in
diesen Zwiebeln abgebildet werden
wir haben aber nicht dass das Zielbild
abschließend formuliert weil das im
Grunde die Aufgabe der Beteiligten ist
auf Bundes- und Landesebene aber wir
brauchen sicherlich eine
Notfallversorgung die aus dem sektoralen
Betrachtungsweisen herauskommt wir
brauchen zentral die
Zusammenführung der
unterschiedlichen
Notrufnummern und Rufnummern in einer
zentralen gesundheitsleitstelle die als
Lotse für die Patienten
fungieren kann wir brauchen bundesweit
einheitliche standardisierte
strukturierte notruf-
eine stärkere sozialmedizinische und
psychosoziale
Komponente im Rettungsdienst vorhin das
Beispiel aus Berlin hatte das ja
angesprochen da ging es um einen
psychiatischen Notfall dafür sind die
die
Strukturen und die
zurzeit funktionierenden
Systeme nicht ausgerichtet sondern
auch da wäre dann dann Kopenhagen ein
gutes Beispiel da Kopenhagen hat genau
in diesem Bereich spezielle
Versorgungseinrichtungen geschaffen
mobile Versorgungseinrichtung für
psychosoziale
Notfälle wir brauchen eine
Festlegung von einheitlichen
planungsparametern und im Grunde muss
der Bund
solange die Finanzierung durch die
Krankenkassen erfolgt der Bund muss
verbindliche Vorgaben machen was muss
sie Krankenkasse eigentlich finanzieren
was muss eine Leitstelle leisten die ja
auch von den Krankenkassen mitfinanziert
wird was muss die Rettungsdienst leisten
was müssen andere Beteiligten leisten
das ist bisher sehr vage oder gar nicht
geregelt und überlässt es im Grunde den
Beteiligten auf bundeseben sogar auf
kommunaler Ebene diese Lücken zu füllen
hier ist der Bund gefordert und das
müsste auch als ein wesentlicher
nächster Schritt im Rahmen dieser
Leitbild Diskussion
erfolgen und wir müssen sicherstellen
dass wir ein letzter Punkt noch das dass
wir eine Qualitätssicherung haben die
bundeseinheitlich Erfolg so dass wir
sicher gehen können dass imagine
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und genauso viel
Ressourcen zur Verfügung stehen
und wie wie in Baden-Württemberg oder in
Bayern und das werden mit den gleichen
Standards die Versorgung gewährleisten
klare Forderung von Thomas Krafts an die
Politik Gesundheitswesen Experte
Professor an der Universität in
Maastricht herzlichen Dank für Ihre
schulde Schilderung und auch für die
Ausführung der Ergebnisse in ihrer
Studie vielen Dank
vielen Dank
ich bedanke mich auch sehr bei euch fürs
Fragen stellen vorher schon fürs fleißig
kommentieren und auch für die
eindringlichen Fälle die ihr geschickt
habt vielleicht auch als Abschluss von
diesem Stream zwei Kommentare die wir
noch mal rausstellen wollen von Stefan
Kellermann vielen Dank an alle
Rettungssanitäter und auch an Notärzte
von Mike W Punkt auch noch mal Respekt
an alle die in diesem Beruf arbeiten ihr
seid tolle Menschen wünsche allen einen
guten Rutsch ins neue Jahr ich glaube
dem kann ich mich und den können wir uns
das ganze Team nur anschließen ich
bedanke mich von Herzen bei euch für
dieses erste halbe Jahr das hat mir
riesig Spaß gemacht mit euch und ich
sag's einfach mal wieder pinke Panther
heute ist nicht alle Tage wie hier von
ZDF heute live kommen wieder keine Frage
und bis dahin noch einen guten Rutsch
für euch macht euch gut und vergesst
nicht auf euch und auf eure Lieben
aufzupassen das tut gut und ist wichtig
ciao